good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 3166 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures the Garfield media franchise
is to remain active and successful for
as long as feasibly possible funding is
to be provided to any Garfield media
ventures via foundation front companies
present in the comic and film industries
agents embedded within paws incorporated
sole owner of the rights to Garfield and
Andrews McMeel syndication primary
distributors of the Garfield comic strip
are to place targeted mimetic agents in
outgoing comic strips encouraging the
retention of a sizable Garfield fanbase
and discouraging Jim Davis from
discontinuing Garfield agents are to
monitor individuals at significant risk
of attack from a CP 3166 in the event of
an SCP 3166 manifestation agents are to
use supplied frozen lasagna to lure SCP
3166 away from its target and dispatch
it once out of public view any witnesses
are then to be administered amnestics as
appropriate for their level of exposure
description SCP 3166 is a two point 1
meter tall humanoid entity presumed paid
a physical in nature known to manifest
during periods when the Garfield media
franchise is performing poorly in terms
of public reception the exterior layer
of SCP 3166 his body resembles a crudely
made costume of a character Garfield
which field inspection is shown to be
composed of legitimate cat fur
however analysis of SCP 3166 is
composition in the field has shown that
it's interior mass is composed entirely
out of pasta specifically lasagna upon
the criteria for its manifestation being
met SCP 3166 will appear in the vicinity
of a suitable individual hereafter
referred to as the target and moved
towards their location known targets of
SCP 3166 have included individuals
prominently involved in rival media -
the Garfield franchise individuals
formerly involved in the production of
the Garfield comic strip individuals
involved in parodies of the Garfield
franchise vocal critics of the Garfield
franchise and Garfield creator Jim Davis
this has only occurred on occasions
where the negative reception Garfield
was receiving could be traced back to
mr. Davis's management of the franchise
upon reaching its target SCP 3166 will
attempt to inflict bodily harm upon them
through a mixture of blunt force using
nearby objects and forced feeding of
lasagna obtained through self
disembowelment during this process SCP
3166 will vocalize by meowing purring
and screeching in the matter of an
extremely agitated cat lasagna out sinus
CP 3166 is mass has proven to be an
effective form of bait for the entity as
upon seeing it SCP 3166 will abandon its
original goal and instead at
to incorporate the pasta into itself SCP
3166 first manifested on October 23rd
1989 within the Chicago Offices of
United media who were the publishers of
the Garfield comic strip at the time
upon manifestation SCP 3166 wandered
around the offices in a confused and
distressed manner before
indiscriminately assaulting any
individuals present after security
attempted to apprehended it D manifested
20 minutes later foundation agents
responding to the situation distributed
amnestics as appropriate over the course
of the following week similar
manifestations took place at a number of
United media offices around the country
ending on October 29th 1989 following
that date SCP 3166 altered its behavior
to its current form see the week of
garfield' comic strips beginning October
23rd 1989 in supplementary document
3166-1 for additional context on pay to
physical awakening initially individuals
involved with the production of Garfield
comic strips claimed to have no memory
on working on that week strips all
researchers working on SCP 3166
containment are to familiarize
themselves on this material
addendum 3166-1 using tissue samples
taken by agent Miller
during SCP 3166 his most recent
manifestation genetic analysis of the
meat present within the lasagne has
shown it to be genetically identical to
garfield creator Jim Davis the
implications of this are currently
unclear however during surveillance of
mr. Davis by containment teams he has
complained of severe mosquito bites in
the night on a number of occasions
immediately preceding SCP 3166
manifestation
all right I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
you walk down the street on your way
home after a long night it's not yet
fully raving but there's still a slight
drizzle about you had the foresight to
wear a waterproof jacket but while it
keeps you dry it does nothing against
the chill the quiet night air the office
wasn't a pleasant place today
apparently the strip isn't doing so well
and the numbers are going down that's
bad news for you as if layoffs become
necessary you'll be the first one on the
chopping block being a new hire is rough
you can't say that the fading popularity
surprises you it's been the same stale
strip for years now but apparently some
investors were really upset some suits
who are prowling around today asking
questions and taking names you stop for
a minute
pulling out your phone to confirm a
sneaking suspicion yep you're headed the
wrong way you shouldn't be anywhere near
the park it's easy to get lost in the
rain you sigh and turn around resigning
yourself to another miserable ten
minutes of slogging through the rain
there's a figure aways ahead of you
standing under a streetlight you stop
again mildly unsettled by this you call
out to them asking if they're okay but
no response comes instead the figure
begins to plod forwards taking a step
into the light the baggy suits slumps
and sangs with each step the matted
orange fur too dirty to be slicked down
by the rain the lazy Ayad faces at an
angle crudely propped up upon the head
swaying as it advances the tail drags in
the puddles only adding onto the stains
already coating it in the rest of the
body
it hefts the old baseball bat it carries
picking up speed you stumbled back
beginning to run away as your fear
catches in your throat emerging as a
strangled cry you alternate between
turning around and glancing back over
your shoulder desperate to escape but
I'm willing to let that thing out of
your sight it sucks the bad against the
fence as it runs a sickening thwack
sounding will each blow too focused on
the Beast you don't avoid the puddle and
your foot slides out from under you
sending you crashing to the ground as
the world Wells around you seeing
nothing but darkness and rain a low
agonized meow sounds from above you
immediately followed by a crushing blow
to the hip you scream out in pain but as
you gasp for a breath a horrible wet
tearing noise fills the air accompanied
by another guttural screech then a
dripping slimy mass is slammed into your
face and your monstrous assailant begins
forcing fistfuls more down your throat
man you hate mondays
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Sabha arbiter Sewell Darius tan
the Morrigan Justin day der Nam and
jayvo Jack Corey Barker Chloe Harlan and
Nathan if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Vulcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you